bonjour philippe simonnot merci d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui sur rt france on
l'a dit le gouvernement va devoir
trancher une réforme des retraites vous
semble-t-elle aujourd'hui inévitable
écoutez en tout cas ni chic qui viennent
d'être publiées ne sont pas surprenants
s'attendait évidemment à une aggravation
du déficit elle un peu moins forte que
prévu parce qu'on tablait sur 30
milliards des 25 milliards fin il est
évident que avec l'effondrement les
cotisations dues à la crise sanitaire
ours attendaient un déficit non par
rapport à ce qu'il était avant la crise
ni les hinton un milliard donc on est
passé de la mignonne samia la question
est maintenant comment on va boucher ce
trou que s'ajoute à beaucoup d'autres
trous dans les finances publiques ou
dans les finances sociales
justement en ce qui concerne c'est la
réforme des retraites est ce que est ce
qu'on peut attendre quelque chose dans
l'émoi dans les années à venir écouter
d'abord on peut regretter que cette
réforme n'ait pas abouti parce que la
réforme telle qu'elle était programmée
notamment le recul un dollar près d'être
une seconde chose et si on avait un
complice cette réforme un temps on
aurait pas un problème aussi grave qu
aujourd'hui
alors maintenant nous sommes en pleine
crise évidemment et la réforme bien plus
difficile parce que qu'est-ce que c'est
que cette réforme c'est tout simplement
en termes clairs va pas se lancer
les arguties qu'on a connus avant la
crise a dit et c'est tout simplement
reculer l'âge de la presse pour financer
évidemment aujourd'hui il doit y avoir
une levée de boucliers contre cette
réforme qu'on appelle pas à metric comme
c'est un grand mot qui signifie
simplement aucune âge de la retraite à
ce qu' il ya un show mal non et donc
l'argument vert est si vous augmentez la
durée de travail
vous avez vous allez encore aggraver le
chômage c'est un argument qui font
certainement politiquement qui va
avoir un impact qui va être pris par les
syndicats et par une toutes les
oppositions donc le pronostic c'est que
on va essayer de faire passer l'orage et
qu'on va reporter un peu plus dans le
temps le financement c'est difficile et
que ceci va s'ajouter aux veuves de
physique etc on passe son temps dans ce
pays comme dans d'autres pays mais
peut-être tizi encore plus qu'ailleurs a
repoussé nos échanges pour quand même
rappeler ce fait basique c'est que le
départ à la retraite en france et 500
tôt en moyenne que dans les autres pays
européens donc l'idée c'est quand même
eux ne se sortira de sceptre ne s'éteint
pas ces crises qu en travaillant
davantage
philippe simonnot vous parler d'un pacte
de de l'épidémie bien sûr sur le sur le
système des retraites est ce que ce
nouveau déficit risque donc de rang
flammes et l'opinion publique et de
revoir une nouvelle fois les gens dans
la rue les syndicats aussi dans la rue
elle m'a écouté lille oui sans doute
évidemment tout va dépendre encore
retrouver des plantes ou même de la
porte du gouvernement
à mon avis il a autre chose à mettre sur
la table remettent dans les formes des
retraites donc pour le moment je pense
puis je ne sais pas ce que veut dire
sinon ce soir je ne pense pas qu on met
ça sur la table tout de suite les
problèmes plusieurs genres qui est le
chômage qui est la relance de l'économie
qui ne les investissements qu'il faut
faire ou qui ne faut pas fait les
entreprises qui conseillent ils s'aiment
qu'il ne faut pas sauvés sk
donc c'est fait je pense qu'un combat en
vain tout de suite remettre ce sujet qui
france
simoneau ce déficit
et pour l'année
20 est ce qu'il est amenée à se
poursuivre en 2021 2022 et peut-être
après oui c'est prévu oui bien sûr à
partir du moment où le système n'est pas
réformé à partir du moment où la
croissance des ports rendez-vous à
partir du moment où les paramètres n'ont
pas chômé qu'évidemment d'ailleurs si
prévu déjà programmés puis 6 5 6 na
parents ils n'ont que le neveu
le tout ne peut que sa grand pin merci
beaucoup philippe simonnot d'avoir été
avec nous cet après midi sur rt frange
rappelle que vous êtes économiste et
auteur de european center of policy
center de l'art hégémonie merci beaucoup